WAI CHEE DIMOCK: OK, so I just
want to go back very briefly
to our approach to
As I Lay Dying.
Last time we talked about the
importance of the epic
tradition to the modernist
novel, especially the way that
the voice of the dead and
certain boundaries between the
human and the non-human are
being reactivated and
redeployed in As I Lay Dying.
So today, we're going
to move on to a
somewhat different approach.
This is really a different
way to
contextualize As I Lay Dying.
And it's more of a kind
of an American
tradition for this novel.
And in fact, we already begin to
see a little of that in the
person who is in one sense a
key player but in another
sense not--
Addie's partner in the
adulterous affair.
And Faulkner takes the name of
that person from a historic
figure, a very well known 18th
century preacher, George
Whitfield, someone who actually
has a large presence
in Benjamin Franklin's
autobiography.
So this is the very
dignified looking
historical George Whitfield.
And this is Faulkner's
Whitfield.
When he was on his horse, he was
able to cross the river,
as we know.
And he's on his way.
In fact, he's approaching
us right at the house.
So Whitfield has a lot
to be thankful for.
And he's expressing
his gratitude
to God at this moment.
"It was He in His infinite
wisdom that restrained the
tale from her dying lips as she
lay surrounded by those
who loved and trusted her;
mine the travail by water
which I sustain by the
strength of His hand.
Praise to Thee in Thy bounteous
and omnipotent love;
O praise."
Yes, he truly is a
very lucky guy.
She dies before she is able
to give away his name.
Maybe she never plans on it.
She's too proud and never wanted
to give away his name.
So he's lucky in having chosen
the right partner.
Someone whose lips are sealed
when it comes to his name.
And he's also very lucky in the
sense that this horse is
such a good swimmer.
The horse is able to cross the
river when the mules drown.
He's truly a blessed figure.
But of course, I'm making fun
of him as indeed I think
Faulkner wants us to.
The only way I think to take
someone like Whitfield is to
put him in one particular
genre.
And this is really what I'd
like to argue today is the
question of genre for
As I Lay Dying.
The only way to take Whitfield
is to put him in
the genre of comedy.
And he's just a comic figure.
He's totally serious himself.
He's congratulating himself and
he's praising the Lord.
But all the time that he's
doing that, he's firmly
ensconced in the comic
tradition.
And it turns out that this
self-congratulating
self-dignifying kind of person
actually has a precedent in
America literature, a very
prominent precedent.
And it turns out that this
predecessor is also a minister
who has an affair
with a woman.
So there's only one novel
in American literature
that is like that.
And not surprisingly, it's a
novel that we all recognize,
The Scarlet Letter.
So this is Hawthorne's
comic figure.
The Scarlet Letter is
not really usually
read as a comic novel.
Like do you think that Hawthorne
has had more fun
when he's portraying
Arthur Dimmesdale?
"God knows; and he
is merciful!
He hath proved his mercy most
of all, in my afflictions.
By giving me this burning
torture to
bear upon my breast...
Praised be his name!
His will be done!
Farewell."
Exactly the same combination, a
woman whose lips are sealed,
would never give away the
name of her partner.
And the same kind of mercy in
quotation marks from God.
In this case, Arthur Dimmesdale
is lucky.
Not in the sense that he has a
horse who's a good swimmer,
but in a sense that he dies
right at that moment.
At the very moment when he's
thanking God and he is
forgiven, his sins are
forgiven, he dies.
So he is very lucky
in that way.
And it suggests that from the
very beginning, from the
nineteenth century on, a story
that otherwise would have been
taken as tragic actually has
a comic dimension to it.
It's just not very easy to roll
our eyes when we listen
to someone like Whitfield and
when we listen to someone like
Arthur Dimmesdale.
But even as we're rolling our
eyes, I think that there are
other things in those two novels
that is very hard to
roll our eyes over.
So I want to turn now to
this other dimension.
And I want to begin with
Hawthorne by talking about,
honestly, the much more
important, tragic dimension in
The Scarlet Letter and it's
on Hester Prynne.
"The fact of the symbol--
or rather, of the position in
respect to society that was
indicated by it--
on the mind of Hester
Prynne herself was
powerful and peculiar.
All the light and graceful
foliage of her character had
been withered up by this red-hot
brand, and had long
ago fallen away, leaving a bare
and harsh outline which
might have been repulsive, had
she possessed friends or
companions to be repelled
by it."
So just as Dimmesdale and
Whitfield are doubly lucky,
Hester Prynne is
doubly cursed.
She's cursed both in the most
obvious way, because she has
to wear the scarlet letter
for the rest of her life.
And she's also cursed--
well, she's actually
triply cursed.
She has to wear the
scarlet letter.
Her whole being is
transformed.
So all the physical beauty or
the beauty of her mind seemed
to have gone away.
And she's just this very harsh,
forbidding character.
And that other people might have
found repulsive, if she
had friends to be repelled by.
So really, she's an absolute
have not at this point.
Although Hawthorne, as you
guys know who've read The
Scarlet Letter, Hawthorne
actually qualifies that this
isn't quite the absolute ending
of The Scarlet Letter.
It's quite early.
So this is a kind of low point,
absolute low point, the
most tragic moment for Hester
in The Scarlet Letter.
And I want to turn now from
Hester to the comparable
figure in Faulkner's
As I Lay Dying.
And obviously, it is Addie.
And she's especially tragic
in relation to the
two men in her life.
First of all, her relation
to Whitfield.
"While I waited for him in the
woods, waiting for him before
he saw me, I would think of
him as dressed in sin.
I would think of him as thinking
of me as dressed also
in sin, he the more beautiful
since the garment in which he
exchanged for sin
was sanctified.
I would think of the sin as
garments which we would remove
in order to shape and coerce
the terrible blood to the
forlorn echo of the dead
word high in the air."
This is about as joyless
a description
of any kind of romance.
It's not even a romance.
It's not adultery.
There's no sex, obviously,
in As I Lay Dying.
There's almost no love.
It is just the whole act
itself is coercing "the
terrible blood to a forlorn
echo of the dead... air."
It's hard to understand why
anyone would even want to do
that if that is the nature
of the affair.
But that's how Faulkner would
like us to think of that
affair between Addie
and Whitfield.
And we can almost sort of see
why she would be so forlorn,
because the fact that he's
congratulating himself and
because he's counting himself
lucky at the moment of her
death suggests what kind
of a lover he has been.
So maybe it's not surprising
that she should have been
forlorn all the way through.
And it is also the
case that she's
forlorn for another reason.
And maybe that's why she got
into the affair to begin with.
Her relation to her husband.
"...and I would think, Anse.
Why Anse.
Why are you Anse.
I would think about his name
until after a while I could
see the word as a shape, a
vessel, and I would watch him
liquefy and flow into it like
cold molasses flowing out of
the darkness into the vessel
until the jar stood full and
motionless, a significant shape
profoundly without life
like an empty door frame."
It's one of the most memorable
descriptions of a terrible
marriage, unbearable marriage.
And I think that that
says it all.
It doesn't exactly justify
Addie's action if it needs
justification.
But it really explains a lot.
And it's in contrast that to
that cold molasses in a jar
that all of a sudden, we
see another marriage in
perspective.
So I just want to refresh your
memory about what we saw last
time about Tull and Cora.
"...because it would take a
tight house for Cora, to hold
Cora like a jar of milk in the
spring, you've got to have a
tight jar or you need a powerful
spring, so if you
have a big spring, why then you
have the incentive to have
tight well made jars, because it
is your milk, sour or not,
because you would rather have
milk that will sour than to
have milk that won't, because
you are a man..."
So it's not a spectacular
marriage
or this good marriage.
And it's a marriage that makes
Tull feel like a man and
probably Cora like a woman.
I don't mean to be sexist. Just
the general description
of a good marriage.
So here's Tull and Cora as a
foil really to Addie and Anse.
So it seems that right now we've
seen Addie mostly as a
tragic figure in relation to her
two men and as a kind of a
descendant, twentieth century
descendant of Hester Prynne.
But given the precedent of
Hawthorne, given that there's
really a comic dimension, even
in the most tragic tale, we
shouldn't be surprised that
there would also be a
comparable comic dimension in
As I Lay Dying as well.
So I like to read the whole
novel as, in some sense, a
kind of constant negotiation
between those two poles,
between the comic pole -- comedy
on the one hand and
tragedy on the other.
And we can see the comedy coming
in Addie's relation to
her son, Vardaman, who's
not quite fully
retarded as Benjy is.
But Faulkner is really
interested in the slightly
retarded mind.
So Vardaman seems to be
an instance of that.
And it comes out in statements
like "my mother is a fish."
I think that along with "Call
me Ishmael," "My mother is a
fish " has got to be one of
the most famous lines in
American literature.
So this brings us back to the
human and the non-human.
But it also now suggests another
dimension, a generic
dimension, to Addie
being a fish.
And it turns out that she's not
just any kind of a fish,
but she's a fish out of water,
which is, I guess, a comic
restatement of the sense of
desolation and the forlornness
that she feels towards Whitfield
and towards Anse.
It is exactly the same thing,
except that when we say that
she's a fish out of water,
there's a complete different
set of connotations.
So this is Vardaman reporting
on this fish that he just
picked up, dead fish already
dead that he's chopping up.
Oh, sorry.
This is actually
Darl reporting.
"'You clean it,' Anse said.
He don't look around.
Vardaman comes back and
picks up the fish.
It slides out of his hands,
smearing wet dirt on to him,
and flops down, dirtying
itself, gapmouthed,
goggle-eyed, hiding into the
dust like it was ashamed of
being dead, like it was in a
hurry to get back hid again."
So along with the sense that
Addie is a misfit that is
completely alone and by herself,
even in a marriage
and even in an adulterous
affair, there's this
additional element that she's
ashamed of all of it.
And we can see that shame in her
reaction to the horse that
Jewel acquires.
She's proud.
She is proud, but she's
also crying.
And Darl realizes that
she's ashamed of her
deceit at that moment.
So there's this terrible shame
that's going to accompany her
in her death.
And in the fish, it comes out
as the fish being ashamed of
being dead, even though
that's not a condition
that we could help.
But nonetheless, this fish seems
really ashamed of this
elemental fact.
Actually, just to stop
for a moment.
The fish actually would be a
great paper topic for your
final paper.
And it would bring Hemingway
and Faulkner together in a
really interesting way.
So once again, I want to
reemphasize how interesting it
might be to pick something that
is peripheral, not a key
player, but interesting entry
point into novels.
So in thinking along those
lines, we can go back to the
fish in In Our Time.
And it's a dead fish,
two dead fish.
But totally different set of
connotations that Hemingway
brings to the dead trout.
"Nick cleaned them, slitting
them from the vent to the tip
of the jaw.
All the insides and the
gills and tongue
came out in one piece.
They were both males, long,
gray-white strips of milt,
smooth and clean.
All the insides clean and
compact, coming out all
together."
So this is Hemmingway's
idea of a good death.
It's the death of human beings
being actually prefigured or
maybe encoded into this very
clean, very dignified
death of the fish.
There's no way we
can avoid dying.
But the least that we can ask
for is that we should die in a
manner that is fitting for men
that is commensurate with the
way that we've lived.
And the trout has lived a very
clean life -- it's an
important word to Hemingway --
has lived a very clean
life in the water.
So it is fitting that
the death should be
commensurate with that.
And that is really a kind of
Utopian moment in Hemingway.
And in contrast, this dirty
fish out of water being
ashamed unto death is a
dystopian moment in Faulkner.
But it's also a comic
moment as well.
So I wish to say that comedy's
obviously a very complicated
and packed and in many
ways contradictory
phenomenon in Faulkner.
And it's with that
understanding--
comedy in quotation marks-- in
many ways, that I like to
think about the whole structure
of As I Lay Dying as
negotiation between comedy
and tragedy.
And I like to bring up three
sets of terms that we've been
talking about all through the
semester to see how comedy and
tragedy get mapped
onto these times.
One is the human and non-human
that we've been
talking about last time.
And then I want to bring
Hemingway back.
In turns out that the two
categories, the have and have
not, set up by Hemingway will
be key actually, in the rest
of the novels that
we'll be reading.
So we're using have and have not
as key terms within there
as a very useful analytic
paradigm and related to those.
Since we've been talking so much
about kinship, beginning
with The Sound and the
Fury and also now As
I Lay Dying, brothers.
Who is a kin and who
is a non-kin?
Last time we saw that Jewel is
in danger of being labeled
non-kin by his brother Darl and
by his sister, Dewey Dell.
So who is going to
be a non-kin at
the end of this novel?
But first, let's start out with
the most obvious comic
feature of As I Lay Dying, which
is the most conventional
ending, happy ending
in marriage.
And if you guys haven't gotten
to that point, I apologize.
But there's no way to talk about
it as comedy without
talking about the very
last thing that we
see in As I Lay Dying.
"'It is Cash and Jewel and
Vardaman and Dewey Dell, ' pa
says, kind of hangdog and proud
too, with his teeth and
all, even as he wouldn't
look at it.
'Meet Mrs. Bundren.'"
So his wife isn't quite
in the ground.
And this is a very fast mover,
so he has acquired a new wife
and other possessions, where
he has teeth and so on.
This is a new feature on Anse.
So this is sort of the cliched
ending for comedy.
You've got to have a marriage
and Faulkner very obligingly
gives us a marriage at the
end of As I Lay Dying.
But we just know that
he's going to
qualify it in some fashion.
So right before we see Anse with
his new wife and his new
teeth, we see something
else and that is just
taking one step back.
"'Who's that? ' Then we see it
wasn't the grip that made him
look different; it was his face,
and Jewel says, He got
them teeth.' It was a fact.
It made him look a foot taller,
kind of holding his
head up, hangdog and proud
too, and then we see her
behind him, carrying
the other grip--
a kind of duck-shaped woman
all dressed up.
And then I see that the grip
she was carrying was one of
them little graphophones.
It was a fact; all shut up and
pretty as a picture, and every
time a new record would come
from the mail order and us
sitting in the house in the
window listening to it, I
would think what a shame Darl
couldn't be to enjoy it too."
So a lot of information is
coming at us at this moment.
New teeth, another possession
records for a gramophone.
And the new phenomenon of
records coming by mail order.
This is truly the twentieth
century.
Even though there's still mules,
we're firmly in the
twentieth century.
And the crucial little detail at
the end that Darl won't be
there to enjoy the records.
So we know right there-- this is
the very end, this is 260--
so we know already what
has happened to Darl.
But it's just repeating what
-- we have no pride
in this moment --
that this is reconstituting
of the Bundren family.
That one person is no longer
kin, no longer in that family.
So how does this happen is what
we need to find out. and
we have to go back a few steps
to find out how it is that
Darl gets excluded from
that family circle.
But I just want to give you
a couple of images why the
gramophone would be such a
desirable object, just like
the telephone.
All this new equipment is just
incredibly glamorous when they
first appear.
So this is Columbia
gramophone.
And I'd like to, since we have
all these desirable objects
here, is obviously As I Lay
Dying is Faulkner's version of
To Have and Have Not.
And right there we know that
Anse has three very prized
possessions, teeth, wife
and gramophone.
And it seems that in contrast,
other people
have all lost something.
They all have been reclassified
in some sense as
"have nots."
So in many ways, this is a
zero sum game in As I Lay
Dying that one person gets a lot
of stuff at the expense of
someone else.
It's a very austere economic
model that there's no pure
gain in this world.
Someone gains something, someone
loses something.
And the three people who lose
something in the course of
Anse acquiring so much
are his three sons,
Cash, Jewel and Darl.
So let's just look at Cash.
And this is not really related
to anything that I've been
saying so far.
But it's clearly
Cash and Jewel.
Cash is the petty cash, and
Jewel is the one whose value
cannot be reckoned by cash.
So Faulkner's really playing
with the economic
model in a big way.
So maybe it's not surprising
that it would also be a kind
of economic logic that's
determining the narrative
logic in As I Lay
Dying as well.
But Cash being named after petty
cash, he's one who would
go try to make $3 at the risk of
not seeing his mother when
she dies, not being with his
mother when she dies.
So petty cash.
But even though his being is
measured by petty cash, even
in spite of that, he can't
always hold on to what he
has-- the little he does have
initially starting out.
"His face turned up a second
when he was sliding
back into the water.
It was gray, with his eyes
closed and a long swipe of mud
across his face.
Then he let go and turned
over in the water.
He looked just like an old
bundle of clothes kind of
washing up and down
against the bank.
He looked like he was still
laying there in water on his
face, rocking up and down a
little, looking at something
at the bottom."
So Cash is momentarily
non-human.
He's lost his humanity.
He looks like a bundle
of old clothes.
And we can all do that.
If we're floating the river
unconscious, we can look like
we're inanimate matter,
which is what
Cash is at this moment.
He could be inanimate matter,
like a bundle of old clothes.
Or we can also think about
different kind of a kinship
that is snapping in place.
Because actually Faulkner makes
sure that we have a
vivid memory of something else
that also floated before
lifeless in the water.
"Between the two hills, I
see the mules once more.
They roll up out of the water
in succession turning
completely over, their legs
stiffly extended as when they
had lost contact with
the earth."
So the mules are floating
belly-up, their
legs stiffly extended.
That's a kind of a natural
posture for them.
And Cash is floating face down
where he's looking at
something at the bottom
of the river.
But either way, the two
postures are almost
symmetrical in a sense that both
the mules and Cash are
reduced to inanimate matter
in that kind of posture.
And we know that the mules
are emblems for Tull.
And they're also emblems for--
it's not cow, it's Cash--
it's for Cash's kinship, that
he too is a creature
with feet of clay.
So this is reaffirming the fact
that he's not capable of
lots of things.
He's a very good carpenter,
but he's not capable of
surviving in hostile
environment, and the water is
one of them.
So right there is just that
kinship has been reaffirmed.
But we can also see Cash
as an ironic instance
of a have as well.
And this is something that would
actually come into play
in a big way in the last
Hemingway novel that--
in fact, it comes into play
in two Hemingway novels.
I promise you that this ironic
use of the have will be a
central moment in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
So we have that to
look forward to.
But we can also look back to an
earlier moment in To Have
and Have Not.
When Harry Morgan is dying,
he's unconscious.
And he feels there's rubber
hose inside of him.
So when we're talking about
that moment, I was
suggesting-- although I wasn't
pushing very hard on that--
that there was a moment of an
ironic have. We don't actually
rubber hoses inside
our bellies.
But it can sometimes
feel that way.
And so it's an ironic
possession, a very negative
possession ironically
invested in us.
And here, it's the same
idea in Faulkner.
Cash as having an ironic
possession that turns him into
a casualty as it did
Harry Morgan in To
Have and Have Not.
"Cash has a broken leg.
He has had two broken legs.
He lies on the box with a quilt
rolled under his head
and a piece of wood
under his knee.
'I reckon we ought to left him
at Armstid's,' pa says.
I haven't got a broken leg and
pa hasn't and Darl hasn't and
"It's just the bumps,' Cash
says. "It kind of grinds
together a little on a bump.
It don't bother none.'"
So Vardaman is the one
who's speaking here.
Vardaman is really rubbing it in
that Cash has a broken leg.
He has had two in his life.
He's managed to break both his
legs in his occupation as a
carpenter falling down
from some height.
In this case, just his leg is
broken actually by the horse
and the log.
So that's what he has.
He's lost his tools
at this point.
He's lost his consciousness.
He's lost his leg.
But what he has instead of a
good leg is a broken leg.
That is what is in his
possession now.
So it's definitely an ironic
instance of a have. And
Vardaman is very, very glad
he doesn't have that.
I don't have that.
Pa doesn't have that.
Darl doesn't have that.
So definitely it is the verb
to "have" is a liability.
So that is an instance of
ironizing that verb.
But there's also kind of a
straightforward instance of
Cash as a have not in a very
simple, quantifiable way.
And actually, quantification
is kind of interesting in
Faulkner as well.
If we think of the entire novel,
the whole narrative
economy is kind of
zero sum game.
They're actually quantifying
who gets what and measuring
that against who loses what.
Actually, there's kind of
quantifying logic going on in
As I Lay Dying.
So this is a quantifying moment
in As I Lay Dying.
We know that the mules have
drowned, so they have to get
another team of mules.
These are very, very
poor people.
A team of mules would
cost $40.
And it seems that Anse actually
has managed to come
up with the $40.
So Darl is trying to figure out
where he got the $40 from.
"'So that's what you were doing
in Cash's clothes last
night, ' Darl said...
'Cash aimed to buy that talking
machine from Surratt
with that money, ' Darl said.
Anse stood there mumbling
his mouth.
Jewel watched him.
He ain't never blinked yet.
'But that's just $8 more,' Darl
said, in that voice like
he was just listening and never
give a durn himself.
'That still won't buy a team.'
Anse looked at Jewel, quick,
kind of sliding his eyes
that way, then
he looked down again.
'God knows, if there were
ere a man, ' he says.
Still they didn't say nothing.
The just watched him, waiting,
and him sliding his eyes
toward their feet and up their
legs but no higher.
'And the horse,' he says."
So we know exactly what it takes
to reach that $40 mark.
He has to get $10
from Dewey Dell.
There's no time to
talk about that.
It's just straightforward.
She owes $10 from Rafe
for the abortion.
And he got the $10 from her.
And he gets $8 from Cash.
Cash was going to use that
to buy a telephone.
That's very far from
that goal of $40.
So one very valuable thing has
to be traded in order for him
to get the $40.
And there's just
one thing left.
It's the most obvious item
that is in anyone's
possession.
So we can turn now to--
Jewel's horse obviously is key
from beginning to end.
But since we've been talking
about kinship between humans
and animals, I just wanted to
stop very briefly and once
again, hold down the conjecture
that I think that
what Faulkner here is, in some
ways, taking us back to the
moment when Jewel is both
a horse and a snake.
We talked about that
last time that he's
caught between two poles.
He's both a horse, but also
there's something snake-like
about his movement.
And it seems that that
association with the snake has
been reinvested in Anse.
So we have the image of him
repeated twice as sliding his
eyes towards Jewel.
Sliding his eyes toward their
feet and up their
legs, but no higher.
It is that sliding motion that
realized the human, non-human
configuration in As I Lay Dying
so that it is Anse who
is the snake in the family.
And it's as if Jewel has
suddenly been freed from his
kinship with the snake.
Maybe this is also
a zero sum game.
There's only one person in the
family who could claim kinship
with a snake, Anse.
Anse right here is claiming
kinship with the snake.
So Jewel is going to relinquish
his kinship and be
redefined in a different way.
But just to wrap up with
Cash he's lost $8.
Once again, true to his name.
That's what he loses.
It's still a very petty sum.
But this is the big loser.
And he has that much in his
possession so he can
afford to lose big.
But let's start out with an
image of Jewel as still a
have. Still having that thing.
When the emerging situation is
becoming clear to everyone, it
is Jewel that Anse
is looking at.
And Jewel has not reacted
in any fashion.
So this is a true turning point
or a critical moment
when things could have
gone either way.
So the horse is still in
Jewel's possession.
He doesn't have to give
up the horse.
It would be impossible
for Anse to take
control of the horse.
He's the last person
to be able to
control that wild horse.
Only one person can control
that horse and it's Jewel.
So this is a critical moment.
How is Anse going to be able to
get a hold of the horse to
sell the horse?
And it seems as if
Jewel is really
tended in one direction.
This is a road that he
could have taken.
But I'm giving it away in
the sense that no, it's
the road not taken.
But this is moment when it looks
like this is the road
that he's about to take.
So as soon as Jewel hears
that the horse
is part of the bargain.
"Then he spit, slow, and said
'Hell' and he turned and went
on to the gate and unhitched
the horse and got on it...
They went out of sight that way,
the two of them looking
like some kind of spotted
cyclone."
Still true to that original
image of incredibly fast
movement, almost superhuman in
the speed with which the two
of them move.
And also superhuman, almost
mythic in the sense that man
and horse had become one.
This is the Hemingway
image that is
transposed onto Faulkner.
This is the closest that
Faulkner will ever get to
Hemingway is Jewel and the
horse becoming one.
So it looks like that Anse is
never going to be able to get
$40, because Jewel and the
horse have cleared out.
Jewel can still be a have
if this were the
ending of As I Lay Dying.
But this is what happens
after that.
"'The horse?' I said.
Anse's boy taken that horse
and cleared out last night
probably half way to Texas by
now, and Anse--' 'I don't know
who brung it,' Eustace said.
"I never see them.
I just found the horse in the
barn this morning when I went
to feed, and I told Mr. Snopes,
and he said to bring
the team over here.'"
So the team of mules
arrives because Mr.
Snopes did get the horse.
And only one person could have
brought the horse to Snopes.
So Jewel becomes a have not.
And we can see why he's losing
his kinship to the snake--
becoming a have not by
voluntarily relinquishing his
possession of the horse.
He is the most tragic figure in
one sense, because he has
the most power to refuse to
relinquish that possession.
And he is the one who actually,
out of his power,
actually, willfully,
deliberately, consciously,
gives up that possession.
So the time has come for
remapping of the whole kinship
structure in As I Lay Dying.
Jewel has, up to this
point, been the
outsider to the family.
He's the one that everyone picks
out as being a non-kin
by Darl and by Dewey Dell.
But this is the moment when
all of a sudden he's been
admitted for the first time
into the family circle.
And what's interesting is that
this redrawing of the kinship
lines is dramatized by Faulkner
as the racialization
of both Cash and Jewel.
And we can see why they
both racialize at
this critical moment.
They become kin, because
they both become black.
"Cash's leg and foot
turned black.
We held lamp and looked
at Cash's foot and leg
where it was black.
'Your foot looks like a nigger's
foot, Cash,' I said.
Jewel was lying on his face
His back was red.
Dewey Dell put the
medicine on it.
The medicine was made out
of butter and soot, to
draw out the fire.
Then his back was black.
'Does it hurt, Jewel?' I said.
'Your back looks like a
nigger's, Jewel,' I said.
Cash's foot and leg looked
like a nigger's."
This is really heavy handed
on the part of Faulkner.
They both look like niggers, and
for two different reasons.
Cash's foot is turning black
because they put concrete on
it to fix the leg.
To fix the broken leg,
the Bundrens have
put concrete on it.
That's the medical practice
within the Bundren family.
So his foot is turning
black at this moment.
And Jewel's back is black
because he has
just been in the fire.
He's the one who actually saved
the coffin, although
it's a dubious thing to do.
He's the one who actually saves
the coffin when the barn
was set on fire.
And as a consequence, he gets
this severe burn on his back.
And that's why his back
is all black.
So each of them actually has
lost something, and they've
gained something.
They don't have a normal color,
like anyone has normal
colored back.
They've got them.
They've gained a black
leg and a black back.
And as a result of being
blackened in this manner, then
all of a sudden, they
become brothers.
So this is a new concept of
brotherhood and new membership
being proposed for that
kinship structure.
Jewel who has previously been
outside of that kinship circle
has been admitted.
And we'll see who is going to
be excluded once again.
It's a zero sum game.
If someone has been let in, who
is it and for what reason
is he going to be left out?
"It wasn't nothing else to do.
It was either send him to
Jackson, or have Gillespie sue
us, because he knowed some
way that Darl set to it."
So everything is interlocking
in Faulkner.
It is that fire that
turns Jewel's back
into a black back.
And the same fire also has
consequences for other people.
You don't set fire to a barn
without someone paying for it.
And it turns out that
it is Darl who's
going to pay for it.
And the language that is used
here-- this is Cash who is
speaking, still in the voice of
someone who's used to being
helpless and used to not being
able to modify the situation
that is given.
There's just nothing
else to do.
One person has to take the
blame and to take the
consequences of that blame.
So one person has to
be sent to Jackson.
And know what Jackson is.
It already has been a looming
presence in The Sound and the
Fury as the ultimate
home for Benjy.
And it is actually the home for
Darl much sooner than it
will be for Benjy.
So let's look at two instances
of the reconstituting of the
narrowing of the
kinship circle.
And Cash talking now and looking
at his brother, Darl,
but beginning to see his
brother as a non-kin.
This is Cash speaking.
Actually, he sort of agrees with
Darl that maybe it's a
good thing to burn
up the coffin.
It's just so humiliating for
Addie to be smelling and to
have all the buzzards
descending on her.
They keep counting 10 and
then more and more.
And everyone --
all the towns they
go through --
wanting to sue them because of
the terrible smell that is
coming from the coffin.
So because of this other
humiliation that's been
visited upon Addie, it would
have been a good thing to burn
up the coffin.
And because it wasn't going to
happen and nobody else was
going to do, Darl was
going to do it.
So Cash can see the reason for
wanting to burn up the coffin.
But he can also see that it
maybe is not such a great
thing for the person
who is doing it.
"... when Darl seen that looked
like one of us would
have to do something, I
can almost believe he
done right in a way.
But I don't reckon nothing
excuses setting fire to a
man's barn and endangering
his stock and
destroying his property.
That's how I reckon
a man is crazy.
That's how he can't see eye
to eye with other folks.
And I reckon they ain't nothing
else to do with him
but what the most folks
says is right."
So Cash ceding his bond with
Darl as Darl's brother.
The kinship bond is superseded
by a much more clear kind of
property relation.
Darl really has no relation to
Gillespie other than that he
is the destroyer of Gillespie's
property.
But it is as a destroyer of
Gillespie's property that he
will get sent to Jackson.
It is that impersonal property
relationship that will define
Darl in the end and not his
kinship with his two brothers.
So this is the beginning of the
exclusion and the logic
for that exclusion of Darl
from that family circle.
But it is Vardaman who
puts the case most
strongly and clearly.
Vardaman talking about Darl.
"He went to Jackson.
He went crazy and went
to Jackson both.
Lots of people who
didn't go crazy.
Pa and Cash and Jewel
and Dewey Dell and
me didn't go crazy.
We never did go crazy.
We didn't go to Jackson
either, Darl."
This is a child.
He's the cruelest, but he's also
the most honest that the
family from now on is going to
be Pa and Cash and Jewel and
Dewey Dell and me, Vardaman.
He's not going to include
Darl anymore.
It's been radically
reconstituted.
And it is on the basis of that
reconstitution that we can
think about Darl as a "have
not," as the ultimate "have
not."
I think Darl and Jewel as
symmetrical in that sense.
Jewel has given the thing that
is most monetarily valuable.
And Darl has given up
the thing that is
most humanly valuable.
This is Darl speaking, referring
to himself in the
third person, talking about
himself in the third person.
"Darl has gone to Jackson.
They put him on the train,
laughing, down the long car
laughing, the heads turning
like the heads of
owls when be passed.
'What are you laughing
at? ' I said.
'Yes, yes, yes, yes,'...
Darl is our brother,
our brother Darl.
Our brother Darl in a cage in
Jackson where, his grimed
hands lying light in the
interstices, looking out he
foams. 'Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes.'"
So he's lost his mind.
That is what there is to lose
in the course of this novel.
He has lost his family.
We know that that's one of the
non-monetary things that can
also be lost. He's lost
his brothers.
He's lost everything.
He's lost his freedom.
And he also has lost his mind.
So we can't really think of
a darker ending than this.
And it says a lot about Faulkner
that this darkest of
endings is actually stuck in
the middle of a story that
actually has a comic ending.
And that's what Faulkner
does with genres.